and this is just part of the problem
this is why we're so diluted because men
if they tell us what we want then all
the other women come in and just C I'm
so guys I am so sick of being pandered
too we're done we are we are as women we
need to come together and say we are
done with the pandering we are done with
the codling because this is what will
happen men will say I like hot young
chicks and then all the other women will
be like oh don't be a doomsdayer don't
be a doom and gloom lady um no that
doesn't help us um selling dreams does
not help women it actually Keeps Us
single childless and alone and this
right there these filters are dreams um
maybe they should ban filters guys do
you think that women that use filters on
their dating apps should be banned for
fraud like if a guy lies about his money
that's that's pretty deceitful why do we
have these filters